and when bad things happen they call
traditionally masculine men if you need
a firefighter you need a masculine man
why are young Muslim men looking up to
the likes of Andrew Tate and Jordan
Peterson the masculine men have a duty
to provide and protect those they care
about is that they're so disgruntled and
they're so resentful at the mainstream
voices out there that they're willing to
latch on to anything that speaks to them
and who are who are these voices out
there it's and it's revolving between
Andrew Tate right and Jordan Peterson
let me into my face
and his final message
[Music]
show
[Music]
subscribe if you have not ready and I
have a special guest which I'm a very
important topic and to cover this topic
of the role of the man world of women
whatever you want to call it feminism
nowadays is taking over and all sorts of
uh people are being looked up to you
have Andrew Tate why are people
gravitating to him towards uh Jordan
Peterson after he uh before he made this
real catastrophe of a decision to go
towards you know having a certain person
on the program you guys know I'm talking
about with the Netanyahu and whatnot but
uh a person who's specialized in this
area I've been talking much about it
want to get him and his
feedback on this my next guest Sheikh
Youssef Susie how are you coming
for having me on how you been how's
everything I'm good and a little nervous
yeah tell us about that well watching
something for years you know growing up
watching your shows along my bedding and
then finding myself in the hot seat is
is is a bit strange right in a good way
this is a very interesting uh I'm
usually the one watching not the one
speaking but it's of your generosity of
having me on your show and considering
me worthy as a Godzilla for having me on
uh thanks for being here I'm going to
get into showing you because the one
thing is nowadays we're seeing a lot of
young men gravitating towards watching
such figures who've kind of uh taken off
in the social media world and out there
like Jordan Peterson and I mentioned him
with a caveat uh because I'm sure a lot
of Muslims are very very upset with this
blunder that he made you know hopefully
turn his life back around and uh make it
right for the decision you know but he
what he did with the Palestinian thing
about their what are your views on that
what we're doing here is a proof for us
on Judgment Day first and foremost uh
another proof against us I mean
um so I I guess to start off a lot of
people are asking and and it really
baffles me as to why they ask the
question is if they don't know the
answer uh so that the typical question
online on social media is well why are
young Muslim men looking up to the likes
of Andrew Tate and Jordan Peterson
that's what I was going to mention next
Andrew Tate you know along with uh
Jordan yeah and the reason I mean a lot
of times when you especially when you're
talking about gender Dynamics you're
talking about equality women the role of
women and so forth you're if you're
going to bring up Andrew Tate your my
extension going to bring up uh Jordan
Peterson and I think the opposite is is
equally true
um when you people are asking Muslims
are asking why are young Muslim men
right um looking up to the likes of
Andrew Tate or even Jordan Peterson and
I think to myself honestly if you you're
either living under a rock or in a
different world not to know the answer
and I think the answer has always been
clear to me at least it's always been
obvious as to why the average young
Muslim man is looking up to these these
uh figures and I find it interesting
that people do not know the answer
however my take on this is that when you
look at how straightforward how brutally
honest how they cut to the chase
these are things that have that are
usually admired when we're speaking when
we're speaking the truth when we're
speaking our heart when we're Frank when
we're candid these are usually traits
that are appreciated in any across
cultures right but what I've seen happen
in over the past decade perhaps too is
that when uh uh uh political correctness
crept into our misajid a lot of these
truth obvious truth claims that have
been truth claims for centuries are now
being selectively pushed under the rug
right and so what you have what I
believe is happening is that Muslim
mainstream discourse is badgering young
Muslim men right you're toxic how you
feel is toxic what you think is toxic
the way you look it's toxic The Way You
Walk is toxic so a lot of these men
they're being badgered right people are
I mean this is what's being said yeah
yes and I talk these are the shabab the
shabab means youth by the way not the
group a lot of young Muslim men this is
how they feel right
um and this is they feel as though
they're being cornered and no one is
speaking to them people are talking down
on them right and mothers are starting
to pick up on this as well and they're
starting to see this in a lot of their
young uh they're young this is from your
experience now being a you're an Imam
also yes yes so yeah you're going to see
this firsthand I see that firsthand and
by the way there's not a community I
visit there's not a community I visit in
America only that a group of Youth will
come up to me and say Yusuf how come
other shifts are not talking about this
right so there's a great deal of
selectivity when it comes to what's
being shown out there what's what are
people addressing and what are people so
young men are coming to you and saying
why are other Scholars other imams uh
not talking or touching upon what
specifically this anything that's right
here anything that's related to Muslim
women is gradually but surely becoming
the unforgivable sin it's becoming
slowly a red line and guess what to be
brutally honest this I feel hurts women
the most it's not doing women a favor
it's not looking out for women that you
completely shove everything that has to
do with women all those topics you shove
under the rug and you limit your
discourse to being good to your neighbor
the mercy of Allah and how we should
vote and to four to five different
subjects right let me let me switch the
conversation here right although this
was not intended when is the last time
you for instance walked into a mess [ __ ]
and you heard the khatib talking about
hijab
the conditions of hijab and you get
around quite a lot right tell me when is
the last time uh I can't remember when
is the last time you walked into the
Masjid and you heard a khatib talking
about how a Muslim woman
is to obey her husband that's an Islamic
concept this is not my ishtihad or my
idea or my opinion
maybe uh
a decade ago a decade ago yes that's
exactly what's happening and a lot of
young Muslim men unfortunately and I am
reluctant to say this but it is the
truth and it has to be set I feel as
though I feel I feel like I'm here to
sound off the alarm because a lot of
young men are starting to see this
selectivity right where are the Muslim
mainstream for example where are the
Muslim mainstream voices who are
speaking as candid and as Frank and as
straightforward as for example Jordan
Peterson
and Andrew Tate and by the way whatever
Jordan Peterson has done that we
obviously completely and wholeheartedly
disagree with what he has done doesn't
take away from the truth that he has
spoken I think people have to stop
mixing up the two right the truth is the
truth irrespective of who said it or
what happened later that yeah there's
there's what's called infica we have to
separate between the two right if it's
the truth he said it or someone else it
doesn't really matter so I believe
there's a great deal of selectivity in
our younger generation they're becoming
disgruntled they're feeling they have
this feeling of resent towards the
Muslim mainstream voice and that's why
today it's you're criticizing the men
all along
but to criticize women constructive
criticism is completely off the table so
in a nutshell this is exactly what's
happening is that a lot of the younger
generation the young men it's not that
they're because what you hear is that oh
these are you know and I find it to be
quite insulting is that anytime the
young men do look up to such figures
oh these are just in cells you guys are
just having a hard time you know Finding
good women that's why you look up to
Andrew Tate and I would I would bother I
would prefer to disagree and say that is
far far from the truth do you look up to
Andrew Tate I mean I the truth I'm not
gonna lie before I heard of him and
before him accepted Islam I saw some of
his clips and I wasn't too fond of it
you'll you're going to find certain
truth claims that certain these truths
sorry I ask you I ask you because this
is what people are asking oh you're
looking up to Andrew Tate so no but no
but but what some of what Andrew Tate
says resonates with uh with us in Islam
such as honor and the husband obeying
the husband being the leader of the
house this this today is controversial
to to say on the mimba this was never
controversial and it should not be
controversial and I am of the opinion we
have to re-normalize this and leave
political correctness if we truly want
productive change we have to leave
political correctness outside of our
pulpits and outside of our message so
there's a difference okay he's saying
some truths but obviously we don't take
him as a role model not at all not at
all and and plus the brother recently
accepted Islam right why he did or why
he didn't that's none of our business
that's between him and Allah
however the truth is to be taken from
anyone now again you have to consider
the the where the young men are coming
from okay is that they're so disgruntled
and they're so resentful at the
mainstream voices out there that they're
willing and to latch on to anything that
speaks to them and who are who are these
voices out there it's and it's revolving
between Andrew Tate right and Jordan
Peterson and this is why the young
Muslim men are looking up to such
figures let me ask you um after we watch
this video and get your feedback on it
sure will and to latch on to anything
that speaks to them and who are who are
these voices out there it's and it's
revolving between Andrew Tate right and
Jordan Peterson and this is why the
young Muslim men are looking up to such
figures let me ask you um after we watch
this video and get your feedback on it
sure and from being a masculine good man
to a bad man there's no such thing as
too much masculinity if it's genuinely
masculine genuine masculinity is not out
here to hurt people's absolutely the
opposite is out here to protect and when
bad things happen they call
traditionally masculine men if you need
a firefighter you need a masculine man
when you call the police because of the
problem you have you want masculine men
and it's soon as a woman or a man is in
trouble when you look for backup you
look for masculine men and masculine men
have a duty to provide and protect those
they care about we have a duty to do
things we don't feel like doing because
we know we're supposed to do them and
that's why we stayed in the Titanic and
died those were masculine where did you
get your views about this from because
what I grew up with is the family I grew
up around and the father your mother
yeah and the world I lived in and I
think a lot of the things I'm saying now
about masculinity and how people should
act in the world how the world should
function we're considered completely
normal and accepted by everybody only 20
years ago I think the world's just lost
its mind for me to stand up and say a
man should protect a woman now gets to
be called a misogynist and canceled if I
said that 10 years ago everyone would
say duh and what's funny is everyone who
argues against me and says men shouldn't
protect women especially all the
feminists if they were with their
boyfriend the man broke into their house
guess who they'd expect to go downstairs
who do you think think they go
themselves are they going to Afghanistan
no we send men to do these things we
send women in the armed forces too
would you have to generalize when you
make points there are many many
exceptions exceptions do not disprove
the rule no but they're you've got to
concede there are many courageous women
serving in the office absolutely and
utterly completely correct but by and
large traditionally soldiers are men
exceptions do not disprove the rule
well it's not an exception it's the fact
that there are a lot of women on the
Armed Forces correct but if you were to
take the average Soldier they are a male
if you're allowed to say who's a male
and who isn't nowadays I'm assuming
their gender I apologize if you ever
take the average Soldier they're a male
which means that exceptions are the
female soldiers which because there's a
lower percent of them a lower
probability exceptions do not disprove
the rules men do the fight right now in
Ukraine men cannot leave women are
allowed to leave because men have to
fight in the front line and women are
allowed to go to Dubai that is how it is
there's nothing crazy about what he's
saying
[Music]
is that one of those
things that uh he's talking about that
you would agree with of course I'm sorry
as a Muslim how can you disagree with
what he said
but the reason why people seem to have a
fit and an issue with what he said first
off is because Andrew Tate is extremely
vocal when it comes to these issues okay
today we either want someone to
completely agree with us and dive in
knows first and if not oh you're either
completely full-fledged in on my side or
I don't like you and you're canceled
right I complete he took it from my
mouth
if if we were alive 20 years ago give or
take I don't think we would be recording
this podcast because it was somewhat
basic and obvious what the men do and
what what the women do so what he said I
don't find anything controversial but
here's what's happening that I think
we're not really shedding light on the
pendulum has swung so far to One
Direction that now when you try to
Simply bring it back to the middle
that is considered controversial and not
acceptable just just to bring it back to
the middle that's not acceptable by a
lot of people constructive criticism for
a mini today is an insult right so this
is this is I think what's what's
happening let's start with this term
what does this mean for the person that
doesn't know this when you when we use
this word feminism feminist what does
that mean so basically feminism
um
it's it what they what they would uh say
is it's about seeking women's rights or
equal rights with men okay now initially
initially uh uh in Europe This is what
happened is that women wanted equal
rights with their counterparts with with
men however first wave second wave third
wave you know and now to the fourth wave
it is and trust me when I say this it's
not about rights anymore it's about
having equal rights with men okay but
today we're at we're at such a point
it's no longer about equal rights today
unfortunately it is about trampling over
men to praise men today on social media
you can easily get canceled for some
women the only thing they seem to be
interested in is to constantly and
consistently perpetuate The Narrative of
display in men as either rapists violent
aggressive rude or lazy bums
is this the reality it's not the reality
right and so but this is what's being
perpetuated so in short they say that
it's about equal rights with men but
that also remains to be selective right
and Let Me Maybe further clarify the
reason why some Muslim women grow a
number of Muslim women the young and
impressionable the reason why I I would
say fall for this ism is because it
carries a positive connotation so when
you take the word gender equality the
word equality is
independently by itself it's a positive
word it carries Positive Vibes right it
doesn't rub you the wrong way and the
muslima the average Muslim does not
really know what in the world she's
dealing with
the average 17 18 year old comes comes
in and she really comes in with a good
intention but she has no idea what in
the world what a monster this feminism
is that she's dealing with so she looks
at the word equality and says well she
Associates Associates it with uh equal
opportunity
right uh equal pay and these are good
things right so she says okay these are
good things in Islam you know offers
women their rights so these are one in
the same thing
and I I think it's our duty again as
Muslims as Muslim Dua mainstream
speakers leaders of the communities not
to say it's our policy not to talk about
feminism in our Institute because this
is what's happening you have certain
institutes
who say their policy is is for us not to
address feminism for us not to allude to
it and for us not to talk about it and I
find this to be the epitome of the
epitome of deception
I cannot sleep at night knowing that
these women are headed in that direction
and I am convincing myself oh now is not
the time it's not of wisdom for me to
talk about this right and that's why I
am of the opinion I there's no room what
I look at when I view feminism I view it
as This ferocious bear with its claws
right at you
this is how I and this is why I keep
talking about feminism this is why I
keep tweeting about feminism this is why
I keep posting about feminism others
unfortunately in the field are trying to
portray this monster as this nice little
rabbit
I think we all need to smell the coffee
we need to all stand up take a stand and
clarify to the young impressionable
Muslims that this is a dangerous monster
you're dealing with and it's not your
friend it's not your ally they don't
care about you and they are not on your
side
when you talk to uh different women out
there do the majority do they classify
themselves as feminists or you they have
the tendencies that fit into this
criteria as a feminist how does it
usually work well it really depends on
who you're dealing with at what stage is
it online is it in person but what I
have seen online is
over the years they've taken in a lot of
these Concepts the concepts are taken in
yeah the concepts of feminism right how
a woman should be right and so and
that's why you have two epistemologies
here that are literally fighting
toe-to-toe against each other right so
she's a Muslim right she does her five
she prays her hijab but she's heavily
influenced by the feminist rhetoric out
there not realizing that her her idea
the way she views life has been shaped
in such a way that it really still
conflicts with the basic teachings of
Islam right and that's why people I
don't think they realize to what extent
and to what degree this feminism is
dangerous right
um by the way this was not even part of
the plan but I'm going to bring up her
name
feminism is you start off with seeking
rights you start off really with a good
intention and hey I'm just here because
I want to secure I want women to secure
their rights and I want to secure uh
rights for for the Muslim woman they
start off good however
as you gradually start to move forward
you're holding on to Islam on one side
you're holding on to feminism on one
side as the the the car starts to go on
faster and move faster she's still
holding on but she realizes the deeper
she goes or the faster the car goes the
more these two start to separate and
which leads me to name
her sister gave an hour-long podcast and
her ending was gruesome she ended up at
the end of her life commit in suicide
was a sister her story is
she started off as as a normal average
muslimat she wanted to join you know the
feminist group she wanted you know uh to
fight for women's rights and women
Liberation and so on and so forth so see
she got in the movement she she got
deeper and deeper and deeper and now
we're talking about Dylan in private
chats private groups why did your
Prophet do this why does this Ayah say
that how come you have to obey your
husband how come the Quran says you can
only inherit this and the list goes on
and on it starts just compounding that
see that's the issue it starts off
Innocent but it morphs into either
leading you to become a lesbian okay or
it leads you to leave Islam or it leads
you to question Allah's existence or it
can also lead you to Suicide as we've
unfortunately seen with our sister so
again and this is why I keep calling
this ideology or this isn't a monster
now is this going to be the case with
every sister out there no but I think it
is enough for us to see what happens in
animal possess and the reason the reason
why this happened again your your
viewers are all more than welcome to see
her video her sister gave an hour-long
podcast basically explaining how her
sister gradually moved up in this and
she got really deep into it but as Allah
says
Allah has not put two hearts
in in our chest meaning that this could
be literally or metaphorically literally
obviously but metaphorically meaning
that your heart cannot bear to withstand
two loyalties within it
so you cannot be a full practice in
Muslim right and be okay with this but
at the same time
you've adopted these feminists it's
gonna take a toll on you and that's why
Muslims have to really check themselves
the 10 years of Netflix the 10 years of
you know 10 20 years of Netflix HBO TV
shows the music the American Idol you
cannot tell me that this is not going to
take a toll
on the way you view life and it is only
natural that later on when you're
navigating through the quranic texts
you're navigating through the Sunnah
you're going to find yourself at unease
because a lot of what you're going to
come across
is not going to mesh well or conform to
the world's view that you've already
adopted years ago and this is where the
anxiety starts to take place would you
say it's kind of like a you know like a
um you know Windows computer let's say
imagine you're using a Windows computer
and you're out there surfing the the web
and you're just all over the place and
then here comes a malware and here comes
a virus gets in the computer and then it
starts acting up so all these things you
know if it's not filtered properly we
get all these ideas in our mind our
brains like a sponge and all these
things start creeping up and then you
end up becoming a victim to things such
as uh what we're discussing here and
other things and then you don't even
know it before you know it your your
heart might gravitate towards a
particular speaker they might say
something that captivates you and you go
deeper into it deeper into it and now
you start adapting and mimicking and
just uh just repeating the things that
they are teaching you right and then it
starts to conflict you've spent less
time learning your dean and you're over
here learning uh from uh Miss uh
Miss uh Johnson over here whatever you
want to call her name uh Miss feminists
uh on Instagram with her shorts and now
you're starting to
take off in a whole different direction
if I could just um follow following up
with your point there see the whole
world The Whole World At Large these
establishments these multi-billion
dollar corporations right these entities
are very very focused on women but they
are more Super Hyper fixated on Muslim
women because at the end of the day
what's left
it's the Muslim woman who's left right
and so what this is what's happening is
that the whole world is telling women
how to behave how to carry themselves
right and what they could do and how no
one is to tell them what to do no one is
to tell you how to dress no one is to
tell you when to go out no one is to
tell you you're your own agency not your
husband should get into that business
not your father not your brother so
what's happening is the whole world but
then they are telling you what to do but
they're telling you not to but I but
then but on the other end they're
telling you the fashion industry and
then all these other forces are telling
you what to do
of course and so you have that's not
even that though so you have one one
group on one end and then you have when
we're when we're speaking to women when
we're speaking to women
we're doing the same exact thing we're
just reminding them of their rights so
now the the person who comes to
criticize women or to offer legitimate
controversy not not controversial but
legitimate uh uh constructive criticism
all of a sudden that person is boxed as
a misogynist as a male chauvinist as a
woman hater as a man who was dogged out
by women in his past or as a man who's
intimidated by an accomplished woman and
that's what just because he's relaying
certain truths the only because he said
that you know uh Allah placed men as
Leaders over their women folk or because
he talked about hijab or because he said
that women should not be dressed in a uh
in a sleazy way this has always been
quite obvious and it's been very easy
for us to speak about but it's becoming
more and more difficult but I think this
is very very crucial it's that the whole
world talks to them about their rights
and now the the basic mainstream voice
talks about their rights and so who's
left
the way this is perceived is the average
Muslim who adopts this this ISM she's
looking as well so and so is talking
about us and he's criticizing us and
he's telling us what we're doing wrong
oh he must be an incel so you wouldn't
do a hat when Muslim speakers were not
all on the same page it gives the
impression to the average Muslim that oh
these people they just these speakers
they just have a problem with women they
need to sort it out because hey these
speakers are not talking about it so it
must be okay I got news for you when
we're in closed doors we're not saying
that it's okay for you to do that no
we're not arguing or debating or going
back and forth that is it really Halal
for her to be dressed like that no our
we're discussing what's the best way to
go about it Yusuf Susie is deciding that
we have to be vocal about these matters
others are still you know saying that no
you know uh silence is wisdom and wisdom
is the best policy and we have to wait
another 10 years to talk about these
issues I'm sorry this is not the way
things ought to be done have you sat in
private
what has been some of their responses
it's the usual thing is what I usually
get is
um we have to use wisdom
I agree we have to use wisdom but their
understanding of wisdom it's a matter of
which Jihad right
um I disagree with the way they're going
about it they disagree they think
basically now is not the time well when
is the time 30 40 years from now
see had all the other voices had they
been silent Yusuf Susie would not be
talking about this but when you have so
many voices out there influential Mega
voices out there and you're telling me
it's a wisdom to remain silent I'd say
no no no no this is the epitome of
deception and we are heard in our young
Muslim women and so I think we've made a
mistake for the past two decades but I
think it is high time that we flip
things around and we start being vocal
indirect about things that need our
immediate attention are there many
sisters that agree with you because
usually if it's coming from sisters also
would you say it has more of an impact
or
should be coming from
from the community the leaders of the
Muslim Community or
well I think everybody has to do their
part yeah everybody here a Muslim Imam a
Muslim Imam there was this brother who
gave a um a sermon about hijab
okay and there was a woman on the board
and I assumed she was a feminist or a
famous Lima right because by the way I
use the word famously mad just instead
of saying a feminist because a famous
Lima is basically a Muslim feminist yeah
right so I just say famous Lima just in
case someone sees my post out there and
says feminist and it doesn't apply to
her you know that the non-muslim and
that's I specified the word famously
um so he ended up giving a a talk basic
nothing on his own Allah said the Hadith
says and that's it
this individual she went she was on the
board she went out of her out of her way
after the who is this person we have to
make sure we have to vet those who are
going to give future hotbas here why did
he talk about that and she had a fit why
because he was talking about hijab
because he talked about hijab yeah I'm
telling you and she wasn't wearing hijab
see I honestly I don't know and even if
she was it's still that idea of see we
don't realize it but we are at the point
where women now are Beyond reproach see
there was a time I used to believe when
people will say well it's not the fact
you said it it's just the way you said
it I believe we're beyond that it's not
that anymore it's not that I think true
we have to be careful in how we word our
statements and and clarify that but at
the same time
let's be honest there are some people
who've been pampered for so long that
they're amazing they're exceptional
they're just the greatest thing that
ever happened and when you come and tell
them that's really not the case a lot of
them are not going to take it that that
well and I think we're at that stage
right now we've been doing too much see
when you pamper someone for too much
you're too much you're going to destroy
them
when you criticize someone too much
you're going to destroy them and that's
why the balance right between
affirmation and between criticism
there's always been a balance in our
religion teaches that but I think we're
at a point now we're too deep and I
think we just have to stop it put an end
to it now and and just be organic and
natural the way Allah wants us to be
yeah you go deeper you also talk about
the emasculation of men in Hollywood you
know at a higher level and then again
that goes back to what we're watching
what we're seeing having an impact on us
see that's the thing
see if we if we really want to remedy
our problem we have to get out of our
inferiority complex and two we have to
be unique and original we cannot take
everything every Trend that we see in
society and try to islamify it and try
to tweak it and say hey we do too we
have to come to a point and say no
there's no such thing in Islam next
we're not there yet there's nothing that
the non-muslims are doing only that we
want to offer an Islamic version I'm
sorry sometimes we have to be confident
and bold and stand tall and high and say
there's no such Islamic way of doing
that right so when you talk about
emasculation of men this is found in
Hollywood it's found in cartoons right
it's found in commercials right it's
found even in the Disney films right
where the woman where the man is shown
as this weak buffum he's the idiot he
just doesn't have it together he doesn't
have these leadership skills right and
the woman she's the uppity up and she's
the one who's got all her stuff figured
out and the man is just the buffum and
he's he's afraid right in my teenage
years by the way
um I cannot tell you how many men I've
met
who were afraid of their wives when I
say afraid I mean afraid
you could see of course it's the
emasculate it's the emasculine
emasculating of men right and of course
that going back to what you watch it's
going to take a toll on you what enters
your ears in what your eyes see right
those are Pathways to where
your heart you cannot watch this
nonsense for years on end and think that
you're not going to be affected yes
you're going to find the Imam judgmental
yes you're going to find the the speech
harsh do you know why because of all
those items that went through both of
your important Pathways and led to your
heart where do you think it's going to
go it's gonna stay there that's the
malware the virus is coming obviously
yes like the computer example I'll give
you a show I was watching an animated
flick on my way to Seattle to visit this
community not too long ago and it was
the I think it was the movie was called
Rio
is that right does that speak to you at
all yeah it was it was real basic in
short in short it's about two I believe
they're called Macau Birds I don't think
I'm pronouncing that correctly there was
a male and there was a female yeah okay
the male the male was a domesticated
bird
in Minnesota and the other one was a
wild bird the female bird was in Brazil
and it's just so by the way it just so
happened that this the male domestic
domesticated bird happened to be in
Minnesota I don't know why right my
place so he's a domesticated bird and
he's all nice and he's you know very
calm and collect and very reserved and
very you know he's domesticated he's in
a cage and his owner is drinking a cup
of coffee in a nice Library he's not
he's not rough yeah okay and of course
the female the female bird is in Brazil
in Between the Lions and between the
jungle you know she's flying all over
the place and so they wanted they wanted
these animals to get together and
reproduce if you will so they take this
domesticated bird from Minnesota fly fly
the bird all the way down to to to uh
Brazil and of course they get locked up
the enemies they're looking for them the
the birds get stolen the gist of the
story is when you look at the woman and
when you look at the man
the man is domesticated he's the one
who's afraid he's the one who's afraid
of taking risks he's the one of saying
oh my God I can't do that and she's like
would you just get your stuff together
so it's the woman who's leading the pack
now and the man is the little you know
uh scary cat right and of course you
watch one flick two flick three flick
this is going to take a toll on you as a
young Muslim man or a young Muslim woman
and guess what if the voices on the
manaber are oblivious and they're not
pointing these things out it's going to
shape you and this is exactly what's
happening right and for example even
when you watch something like sometimes
some brothers will send you certain
comedy flicks you notice although they
say it and they're trying to be funny
and humorous about it you'll notice
later on that there's a gist of Truth in
it right so when a man goes Golf and he
has to get his wife's permission
um you know uh honey
um no no of course I'm coming you know
but
then when he reverses the role and when
she's talking to him she's all like you
know what if you don't come here now
we're going to have problems and so he
on the other end says okay okay no no
I'll be right there honey no I don't I'm
not playing golf I don't have time for
my friends you know so she's the one
who's basically putting him in check
right not to say that Yusuf Susie wants
one or the other to put you know in
check but it shows you that things are
changing and we have to come to the
realization I think sooner than later to
accept that the man in Islam is the
leader of the household he's the kawam
right
irrespective of how many degrees you
have irrespective of your career
irrespective of how lucrative your
income is you do not become the kawam of
the house that is something that Allah
gave the man and it's not for the woman
don't be mad at me this is basic Islam
it's always been this way
right
what if she says well he's uncomp
incompetent right I'm I'm more fit for
that position
sure and guess what there are certain
situations that are like that right and
that's why when you talk about the so
for instance your this brings in another
subject of hypergamy right uh there's
this author who wrote a book it's called
men on strike and she talks about this
concept of hypergamy and that is that
you find women who are suited to lead
the household but let me ask you this is
that the exception or is that the rule
generally speaking that's the exception
exception yeah that's the that's not the
rule because Allah created it within
them to want to lead I mean Allah
explicitly says in the Quran
right that the men are caretakers over
women or of women right and so it's in
our nature to want to lead and that's
why I think an egregious mistake that we
Muslims have done and continue to do is
to turn the exception into the rule and
the rule into the exception it doesn't
work like that
it doesn't work like that right and if
she's better suited for that position
and they're they're they're you know
they're living in Harmony and things are
working for them good but sometimes the
marriages are miserable because the
roles have been literally flipped upside
down the man wants to carry out the
women's the women's role and the woman
is trying to carry out the man's role
right because again the the pathways
right and what they've been uh taken in
for years on end but they don't realize
at the end of the day they're both very
well off they're they're they're doing
very good for themselves but their their
intimate life their their personal life
their their marriage is miserable
you're seeing this firsthand yeah yes
yes yeah let's unpackage this uh when
you talk about the man he's the leader
of the home because sometimes you know
the environment with all of these um
things that are out there will construe
this with someone who's okay he's he's
the leader of the home does that does
that mean that he is what does that mean
actually if you unpackage that you know
that doesn't take away that he's
obviously he's compassionate he's kind
he's merciful all those good qualities
and that but at the same time he's firm
right he's somebody that needs to be
respected unpackage that Morris you give
a better picture because to to some
people that might be like oh what he's
now has the the authority to oppress me
right to uh that's a that's a very good
question because when people you know
when when you talk about the concept for
example of obedience right uh usually
there's this there's this image and of
course Hollywood has done such a
diligent job over the past decades in
portraying that image of the woman is a
slave to her husband and the husband is
basically just whipping her in doing
don't then stand up sit down you know
and and of course this is too much
television right I mean but can I also
be honest and say that some men have
contributed to this yes
right um some men out there have
unfortunately contributed to the
stereotype right and that is that his
wife for him is basically just like one
of his daughters he doesn't treat her
with respect he doesn't honor her he
doesn't consult her he doesn't you know
get her opinion right so Islam is Islam
is a balanced religion that it wants you
to be a man meaning that you assume
responsibility right that you're not
careless that you are
you're you're driven you have motivation
you are determined you are guiding and
leading the family it's not see
a Muslim man Islam does not ask of us
men to become tyrants in the home but at
the same time that's one extreme the
other opposite extreme of the pendulum
is when you become a doormat
is when you become a yes man and you
think that being a yes man is going to
get you all the results that you've ever
been you know hoping and wishing for and
I'm sorry to tell you you're not going
to get your wife's Respect by being a
Yes Man the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam for example right the prophet
Allah would hardly say no he would say
yes but I can assure you if you look
through his Sita he was far from a Yes
Man okay and if you want to have me on a
different episode we can talk about that
one by one because I I think that really
needs an episode in itself so going back
to what you've asked just so we're not
drifting too far away
um we don't want men Islam is not asking
of meant to be tyrants but it's also not
asking of men to be these doormats where
they don't have a say and whatever he
says she's like I don't care and of
course this is no no God conscious
Muslim woman who who loves and fears her
Creator she shouldn't have that kind of
attitude not at all not at all and
that's why when we talk about a woman's
obedience to her husband
and obviously to keep balance he should
be kind compassionate loving towards his
wife but at the same time he has to make
certain decisions as the protector
maintaining the family to protect the
family so if he makes a decision that
hey I want my wife home at nine o'clock
you know I don't want her go to down you
know go out at this time and she's like
whatever no no she can't do she got to
be home at a certain time can I see I
feel like you're gonna drag me into
something completely different and these
are all interrelated by the way but men
are that's just an example right yes of
course and that's not out of his like
you know being a he's he loves his
family he loves his
it's out of love and protection yeah but
the way the enemies of Islam have framed
the discourse is oh no he's doing that
because he wants to hinder your freedom
and he wants to hinder your rights and
he's your biggest stumbling block to the
Free World but like you said why is a
man doing that
because he knows what a nasty world it
is out there how evil people can be and
guess what for since time immemorial men
preyed on women and it's not the
opposite way around
right and that's why so when we talk
about this concept of obedience right a
woman obeying her husband there are many
a Hadith there are many talk about a
woman's way to Paradise
if she's married is by her obedience to
her husband okay that this is this basic
Islam for someone who's never heard
maybe a authentic Hadith in this area
which one which Couple come to your mind
which who I'm sorry which Co if someone
for someone who hasn't heard one of
these authentic statements from the
master Foundation which two or three
come to your mind when you say two or
three in terms of teeth regarding this
oh so the prophet salallahu he says
this is something that let's say at a
now the Sheikh who's listening maybe he
can go ahead and be refreshed and
mention some of these see I I think but
to be honest I feel like you're being
very charitable and that that's that's
very good in you I I appreciate that
it's a praiseworthy Content at Supreme's
worthy uh character to have but can I be
very honest with you he's already very
familiar with a lot of these a Hadith
right he says for example ayum um
there's not a woman who prays for
example her five and the Hadith is
there's not a woman who prays for five
who fasts the month of Ramadan and obeys
her husband only that on Judgment Day
shall be told
go into any of the doors of paradise you
want but this is this for many women
today because of all of these voices and
what they've taken in it is like
climbing a steep Mountain can she say
well that Hadith is if someone said no
because it's in the Quran too but if
someone says look that's also for women
if let's keep it equal feminist says you
can't you can't you can you use it the
other way if if a man Praises fridayly
prayers if he fast and he obeys his wife
should I be flipped around I mean you
you can but I mean there's there's a
hierarchy that no one can run away it's
inescapable so you can't flip that
Hadith that way if you're a feminist and
you want to keep it co equal no here's
the thing if yeah see that's the problem
you're when you run into this see for
for when you if you come naturally see
let me let me say this right and I know
we're jumping around from point to point
the a woman back home right uh an
elderly woman uh you go to a remote
Village somewhere in some country right
if you tell her a woman is to obey her
husband she's not gonna she's not gonna
look at you and dismay and say excuse me
now this woman probably can't read or
write
okay are you with me yes but if you were
to tell her this she's going to look at
you and say that's what what's new yeah
I okay of course
like this like oh yeah why and what does
the word obedience really mean and how
come I have to obey him well obedience
is me no obedience is not mutual
consultation it's not that I am sorry
is obedience so for example I remember
this one sister and this is why I said
it's dangerous because you start digging
in certain things and you start to
literally throw away the Hadith Corpus
in its entirety because you're not
finding something that suits you is the
general Maxim here is that as long as
he's not calling you to disobey Allah
and his messenger then it's Obedience of
course and all of it is within reason
yeah it's it's it's it's within reason
right we're not talking about crazy
extreme limits right but I think we have
to reinstitute that concept and that has
to be in the peripheral of a lot of
Muslim women that if you're going to
marry this man then you should know that
you're going to get close to Allah by
being dutiful to this man if you're not
ready to do that maybe it's you're not
ready for marriage yeah and uh just
thinking about it do you think that uh
it's been taken to an extreme just like
you have the the hate provocateurs out
there those who are in islamophobia
Industry they take a fringe very small
Fringe element doesn't even add up to
0.001 right let's say some extreme right
a person who does something and uh
brings try and then they try to use that
and tarnish Islam can you flip it here
where they will magnify where you have
obviously you have like you said some
men do some things they shouldn't do
it's opposite of Islam now they focus on
these poor examples and now they
magnifying this as if the Muslim men
have been oppressive to women for
centuries yeah and again that's that's
Fallen prey that's Fallen prey to your
own enemy because a lot of times it's
about how you frame things it's about
how you say it right so because no no
muslim who's praying five times a day
who's TR who has taku of Allah wants to
bring harm to his right his wife what
kind of marriage is he going to have no
no you're absolutely right and I think
again that goes back to making the rule
the exception and the exception out of
the rule right if well let me say this
and I don't mean to be too you know too
provocative or too controversial but if
every man on Earth this if every man on
Earth abused his wife the concept of a
woman's obedience to her husband will
still remain
we're not saying we're not advocating
that no but a woman's obedience to her
husband has always been a Muslim concept
right and I just a a sister I wanted to
mention the sister earlier who said well
there's no such thing there's no
authentic Hadid that says that a woman
should obey her husband but the word is
actually in the Quran where Allah talks
about the the disobedient women right he
says
the word the word far if they or
if they obey you
um
if they obey you then to not transgress
the boundaries when it's talking about
new shoes but there's also another
talks about a man who's not being
dutiful to his wife and giving her her
rights but it doesn't talk about but if
he obeys her
so it's inescapable and that's why it's
better off for us to come to terms with
this as soon as possible because it's
inescapable you you can't I'm not the
problem Wallah yusufs is not the issue
Yusuf Sushi is not your enemy I'm
telling you just the very basic and the
Very obvious that I wish others would
also tell you so I'm not viewed as The
Fringe and and and weird uh Imam if you
will uh does this fall under this uh
would you talk about this mainstream the
domains we talked about on the
mainstream discourse and then the um you
talk about
the pandering now is it because you you
have a is the path of least resistance
and now here you'll get more followers
possibly uh you won't come under certain
scrutiny if you're a person in a
position let's say any mom and now you
have your congregants you have a board
and from here you can get a lot of heat
like you just gave an example someone
was given a hutbah you talk about hijab
and now you had the sister come up and
start to you know really throw a a big
fuss about it do you think this holds
back a lot of Dua scholars imams in the
massaged to talk about some of these
very important issues that you're
talking about very much so
um very much so very much so without a
doubt has anyone admitted this to you
let's see you see no one is going to
come to you see it is an utter
impossibility it's just not fathomable
fathomable for someone to come to you
and say
I'm afraid to talk about this I I just
don't see someone saying that yeah or
I'm afraid of losing followers or I'm
afraid of being cancerous no I don't
think anybody's gonna say that and guess
what I really believe that some do
believe right that I'm doing it out of
wisdom wisdom and I'm trying to
strategize okay some do believe that but
some said look they say look uh Yusuf
look I I want to speak about it but I
can lose my position I'm going to get a
lot of pushback has anyone see I haven't
met someone like that what I usually get
is you know
um you know what we're just trying to
strategize we're trying to be very
delicate with this and hey you know what
I agree with you I wish I wish I had
your patience I wish I could you know
try to strategize but I feel like we're
at a point right now I don't feel we
have the luxury to strategize things
have gotten so out of control you know
when you're desperate yeah when you're
desperate and you're you're on that your
time is ticking you do whatever you can
just to basically get that that liquid
that spilled or the box that's build you
try to put it back together I believe
we're at that stage right now where
we're so desperate and we don't have the
luxury to talk more about strategy than
we do about action
right but to say that I'm also I will
say this it's hard to x that out
right I'm not I don't feel comfortable I
don't have the guts within me to start
digging into the hearts of people right
because Islam taught us not to but I
will say I can confidently say that I'm
not going to X those factors out because
we as imams Muslim speakers Scholars and
so forth
we know what's going to get likes we
know what's going to get us a criticism
we know what's going to get us canceled
we know what's going to get us invited
at the next event we know what's going
to open up the doors we know what's
going to get us brownie points we know
all this before we tweet or type
anything we know the result that we're
gonna get right but it's the selective
the cherry picking in the selectiveness
that's that's hurting the ones we're
trying to help the most women when you
watch this uh popular program that's out
there uh from the Kai's tribe
yeah I mean you have a lot of uh even
sisters who who like this program right
but isn't a lot of the stuff you're
talking about if you watch this you kind
of see people playing their roles yeah
you know it's very funny that you say
that because yes yes and here's the
thing there's there's some Harmony there
big time I mean you look at I mean you
look at whether it's sortogo or bamsi
Bay or whoever these characters are when
their wives talk to them I mean you kind
of see that great honor right and she
just kind of you know look if you can't
do that with your I'm not saying you
have to that that's between you and your
husband I frankly don't don't care it's
none of my business but when you look at
the way women are addressed and the way
women are and that masculinity in the
men you notice a drastic radical
difference between how the women are
right and how they treat their husbands
how they speak with their husbands how
they address the great honor that they
have for their husbands right it's not
that they're being loud and
disrespectful and talking back and who
are you and I'm gonna leave anyways and
I really don't need you it's not like
you're doing you know much for me
anyways I mean look I'm the one who gets
the complaints
I can leave anytime I want to I really
don't need you I'm educated I can do it
on my own when when men these are some
of the statements huh oh yeah oh yeah
Allah is my witness I'm the one who gets
this and maybe this is why I'm
passionate and I'm talking about this
there's nothing in it for Yusuf Susie
I'm not on men on the side of men and
I'm definitely not on the side of women
I'm on the side of the Hulk
there's nothing absolutely nothing in
this for me
is just these are problems that I'm
seeing that have to be addressed and we
have to renormalize this this has to
become the new Norm in Islamic discourse
there's uh one scene
and you'll see was it turgot
Target
yes and his wife is giving him advice
and she's really adamant about how she
wants things and if I remember correctly
to play out he's listened listen
listening and then he's like at the end
he says enough
and he puts it he's firm in the matter
and he makes his decision and from there
she just steps back she accepts that and
then he starts to really open up even
more and he starts to praise her you
know how much he loves her and whatnot
but she didn't keep going back and forth
she was talking talking then at the end
he was like he made his decision
she accepted it heard her out but she
pulled back
she knew the limit right and she
expected that role that God Almighty
Allah had given the man and then it
turned out that he even that love for
her increased see here's the thing
um
nowhere to start really because there's
so much to say
men as men were very basic creatures
were not complicated as women are and
that's not meant to be an insult this is
the way Allah created us right and the
reason why I'm bringing this is because
for example
I believe it's the first page when Allah
is instructed the men to lower their
gaze right he says
in that page there is I think it's one
and a half sentence one two sentences
give or take right that talk to instruct
men uh tell the believing men to lower
from their gaze and to protect their
private parts that's it the remainder of
the page do you know how many lines
we're talking about
a good 10 lines have to do with women it
talks about their Xena who they could
beautify themselves in front of their
Hima and so on and so forth so it's not
me who's saying this men are very easy
creatures we're very we're very simple
and basic women are very very
complicated and no one should have a
problem with that this is just how Allah
in His Infinite Wisdom created us to be
right and that's why I this Society is
teaching a lot of our women don't let
anybody tell you what to do you're
amazing the way you are and I know I've
said this before but when you when you
live according to that style
it's going to be very hard for you to
get married and accept the fact that as
you said earlier your husband doesn't
want you out at a certain time of night
maybe he doesn't want certain friends
over the house maybe he believes that
this friend is not really uh having a
good influence on you that's his right
let's stop right there it brings your
place is that his right where he says if
he sees like a friend if the husband
sees that this friend is not someone who
he wants his wife to hang out with
because he feels that this is
detrimental to her Dean to her
well-being to their family and even
though she has an affinity towards his
friend does in the obedience to Allah
now obeying her husband does he have a
right to say cut this friend off of
course I mean solo and again this is an
example now now we're getting down to
you know some of the sure yes yeah
that's fair this is across all four
methods this is very very basic across
someone can't say no not according to my
method no that that's that's to obey him
in that which is reasonable and then
that which is truth right if he on if he
notices his wife is drifting away her
hijab is changing her attitude is
changing she's becoming a little bit
rude she's becoming disrespectful she's
not appreciating what he's she's overall
changing and a lot of times it takes one
friend to corrupt oh yeah oh yeah no
that's of course that's his right I mean
he's going to be response that's another
thing I think that is not being conveyed
enough I believe on our pulpits is that
we men are the ones who are going to be
asked about our women folk on Judgment
day and it is not the opposite way
around so how does someone go ahead and
check this because someone might be like
pointing the target at you now getting
upset with you and how can someone if
they have to check their relationship
with with Allah with their Deen with you
know if someone has an objection to this
you remember what I said earlier when I
said If a woman is she has it has to be
in her peripheral in her radar that my
husband can be my way to hell
by disobeying him and being ungrateful
to him but he can also be my my first
way ticket to Heaven I think that
peripheral I know a lot of your viewers
are probably not going to be too fond of
this but this is so again I want to
remind everyone this is how this has
always been very basic Islam right and
so if that is not in our radar
everything else is going to become more
difficult and that's why I believe it
starts with that it starts like okay
this is not just any man this is not my
friend at work this is not my colleague
this is my husband
right and that is why it is like like
she says
she knew she knew that she could not be
dutiful to her husband because they're
that compatibility was not there so she
said o messenger of Allah I want to
separate from him yeah because she was
afraid of not giving him his rights that
that and again not that I'm supporting
divorce here or I'm advocating it then
oh just move on but you're probably
going to be better living alone
worshiping Allah than being married to a
man and you're not giving him his rights
and you're disrespecting him and
trampling and walking all over him
that's going to come with consequences
right can I just finish maybe one more
Point yeah if you allow me if you um
look at the page right before the last
page of Surah right
it says that
shaytan
right
shaytan first comes to Adam not to both
of them he comes to Adam and he whispers
to him and he says shall I not guide you
to an eternal tree and an eternal
Kingdom and then Allah speaks in the
duel the two
so they both ate from it right and
they're private parts were just
disclosed right and
then they started to look for leaves in
the Jannah to try to cover their private
parts right and then after that Allah
says
and Adam disobeyed his Lord and he went
astray now look how when who came to who
shaitaan came to Adam
when there was the leader of the pact
the leader of the house he comes to Adam
and speaks to him directly not to both
of them he doesn't pull Hawa on the side
he speaks to but when it comes to the
act of Disobedience Allah speaks in the
muthanna the both the two of them right
in Arabic you'll know this is speaking
of two of them but then when it comes to
the responsibility in the admonition
you find Adam alone Adam
and Adam disobeyed his Lord and he went
astray now who who disobeyed Allah was
it just Adam or was it both of them
both of them right because they both ate
from the tree but Allah is single and
out Adam here specifically in this Ayah
because he is the man of the house he is
the leader he's the one responsible so I
just want to remind every sister out
here it's not your husband's job to sit
there and admire you from afar and for
you to do whatever it is you please
however it is you please I know this is
not going to sit well with some of them
but
a man it's his right it's his very basic
right in Islam to make sure that you're
dressed appropriately that you're
befriending good people that you're not
out in the middle of the night even if
you're doing something good because
again he's afraid of you all of these
have always been basic this is the basic
stuff look into the books of Islam this
is all there yes yes and that's why you
like going taking a math class at the
University or in elementary school this
is like you know math 101. English 101.
it's always been that way oh okay it's
but it's again you're not saying nothing
new now no it's not like I said if I
said this 20 years ago I I probably
wouldn't even have a need to say because
it was just it was acknowledged but
again don't forget when you grow up and
you really have the idea that no one
tells you what to do it becomes very
very difficult for you to get under the
roof with a man who's probably going to
want to tweak a few things yeah right I
mean it's only natural that you don't
want your wife going out in the middle
of the night you know when it's dark or
you know to be in an empty parking lot
by yourself yeah that's natural
what is what is what is so controversial
about that yeah
yeah okay yeah I don't get it it's hard
to see how we came this far you have uh
someone someone who was talking about a
uh older couple who's been together for
almost 40 50 years whatever the case and
and the wife is
um with her husband and everything that
the husband is is um the wife when she's
asked something by their children so I
gotta check with your father you know I
gotta check with your father she's like
you know showing that respect that you
know she's Consulting with him she's not
just on her own sure kind of like
Renegade doing her own thing you know
and it just touched the person who's
watching how there's this respect and
then obviously he's you know very kind
to his wife and this goes back to a
guest I had on the program I think every
Imam I've said this before every Imam
should have this as a part of basic
reading material and then it should
recommend this book it's called
empowered wife by Laura you sent it to
me I haven't read it yet it's a very
powerful book because it's by a
Christian woman she's also someone who
is at the verge of divorced and she went
to traditional marriage counseling and
that's a failure and that's something
that really
um I she advised people to stay far away
from because it's just a milking cow
from your money but then and she went to
people to see how they kept their
marriages who were in marriages for 30
40 plus years sure she went to experts
because how did they keep it together
for so long and she found that and this
by implementing this what she found it
saved her marriage she found that men
needed that respect and it wasn't the
respect like if he deserves it or not it
was just like they just need respect
it's like oxygen and when he would get
that respect he would give her all of
that love reciprocates he would
reciprocate with so much more right and
she found also that there was a lot of
different in her book you open up the
opening uh chapter and she she lists a
bunch of myths like you know how
marriage is 50 50 and I'm just
recollecting some of the things that
sure that it's like a true and false she
goes no women are the leaders in the
sense of if they want peace they'll be
peace because if a woman's unpleasable
you're not going to please her right men
are simple creatures they don't want war
they don't want to fight usually
typically that's how and and a lot of
things that go with dardane with Islam
so this is something that is called the
Surah it's called empowered wife by
Laura doyon supposedly she's helped over
150 000 couples saved their relationship
their marriages yeah see if I could if I
could just mention something I think
what we're overly concerned about is
hurting
the feelings of others
okay now do we want to hurt others the
feelings of others we don't but I think
we have to also acknowledge that
sometimes in the process of conveying a
truth in the process your feelings might
be heard
so I want you to understand dear viewer
or dear brother or sister that hurting
your feelings is not an objective it's
not an end but sometimes to get to the
truth your feelings might get hurt yeah
and especially seeing how far we've
swung I think it's only natural right we
should somewhat expect that that's going
to happen is that because there's so
much layers of layers of layers of
deception of lies of silence and silence
on our part as Muslim speakers yes
silence these sort of things and it just
gets padded padded up you got to just
like it's layers you got to take all
this compounds off the compounded layers
yes now you got to get to it what's the
definition would you say of a good man
well like a good man is a man who's good
I'm being sarcastic no
um uh a good man is we're talking about
Islam right yeah a good man basically
who's going to assume his
responsibilities right a man who's going
to be mature a man who's going to be
confident a man who's going to have a
sense of direction a man who knows uh
what he's doing he has a vision he's is
not a follower right and that's
something that a lot of women they
resent when they see a man who doesn't
have a sense of direction and he's kind
of just a follower right of course I
mean there are so many things to list of
course I mean I think it's a giver when
we talk about fasting you know the month
of Ramadan right these are basic pillars
yeah these are Basics you know um
someone who's not too I mean a lot of
people are probably not going to like
this but I really urge the younger
generation of Brothers to stay off of
these video games right we're not
talking about highlighter how I'm here
but we're just just talking about your
wife honoring you and respecting you as
the man as you wish to be respected I
would definitely urge a lot of our
younger brothers to ease off of the
video games for sure
tell me this uh why why do you feel now
are you seeing more and more men going
overseas going
um to get married you know not staying
here but abroad are you seeing an influx
of this yes yes you know you are yeah
yes why is that big time Big Time
there's again there's not a community I
wrote a I wrote a tweet a while back and
it uh so you really if they want to find
you they can find on Twitter how you're
really into tweeting I I mean I I well
I'm yeah I'm on Twitter and Facebook as
well
um I've gotten myself in trouble
okay
t-a-b-s-i-r-a and then project
p-r-o-j-e-c-t so all the the positive uh
comments and even some of the probably a
few maybe you know negative ones who you
know I'm sure most people agree what
we're saying but you know for the small
Fringe element they can send you those
oh yeah I welcome criticism no one's
above criticism right as long as it's
constructive criticism and it's true I I
have no problem but there's nothing
special about us yeah the truth
transcends us this is look I don't care
what you got going on in your life
there's nothing special about us
nothing right
um so going back to your your question
you said yeah are you seeing uh men
going yeah I wrote a tweet yeah sorry
okay so I wrote a tweet a while back and
it was completely misunderstood but I
can honestly understand how it was
misunderstood uh where I said in it that
as women pursue their degrees in the
west men are pursuing wives in the east
mm-hmm and that's that's a reality
that's an observation there's not a
community again that I visited only that
many young males would come to me and
say Yusuf I'm not gonna lie that tweet
is fact well it is how I went I searched
here for two three four years I could
not first find a woman who's willing to
stay at home
two she wanted to pursue her career and
she I can't keep waiting right and this
is I think what a lot of our sisters are
not understanding they took this tweet
and it spiraled out of control thinking
that shiryusi is against educated women
no there's a reality that's happening
here is that when you're in your early
20s and you have suitors coming your way
and you shun them and you turn them away
because you want to prefer your yours
your I mean do you if you want to do
that I mean bear the consequences right
this young man now he's not going to
wait until 25 or 26 until the sister
graduates with her bachelor's and then
Masters when she's done with her college
education that young man it most likely
is already married now with two or three
kids
that man is not going to wait for her to
for her to finish her degree and now you
find that even in the 30s and the
numbers gradually keep increasing right
um and they're regretting it a lot of
women I saw a tweet just two days ago
were a woman she she's regretful she
says verbatim she says I am depressed I
am in my 30s right now okay and I've had
proposals I've had suitors come my way
in my mid 20 early 20s and mid-20s and I
had to pass them up because of my
education but she says but now I can't
find find anybody to marry me and I
believe it was her father who said if
you want to get married at your age at
your age men at your age are looking for
women in their early 20s didn't they
have some of the they had the biggest uh
studies that were done like from the 70s
up until not too long ago where they did
studies on this exactly what you're
talking about women who went and pursued
these careers and they went away from
you know doing you know getting married
at the young age and having a family and
then they they end up uh regretting it
you know very big time they end up
falling into this depression of course
and regret deep regret and then all they
have right now is they look up and they
see all these uh certificates but at the
end uh they're alone
yeah and Allah the way Allah created us
I mean the the word even in Arabic the
word insane
to be social or to be you know um
there's nothing there is nothing that is
going to replace companionship now I
know some of your viewers might be
thinking oh I got married and it was
hell well that's again that's an
exception and let us also ask ourselves
was it because of you are you sure it
wasn't you are you sure you weren't the
problem right because a lot of women you
make it hell huh that's a possibility
yeah right and I think we have to be
real with ourselves right and being real
requires that we have a sense of
maturity and humility to look at
ourselves in the mirror and say you know
what maybe I was the problem
right so going back to what you're
saying um
we're Allah created us to be
interdependent on one another not to be
independent of one another we are we
count on each other and there's nothing
that is going to replace companionship
that Joy of having a husband of having a
wife of having the kids of going that
that companionship is that you cannot
substitute it it's invaluable
right and I think a lot of people are
being told that no what's important for
you oh dear woman is for you to focus on
your career is for you to gain more
education is to get more certificates
and the list goes on and on well when
you do that at the expense of delay in
marriage you're passing up a lot of good
men and you have a biological clock
that's ticking and and that's of course
decreasing in age as well right Studies
have recently shown that yeah there's um
examples just in uh some of our our
elders if you look at some of your
grandparents I mean if you ask them
right you didn't you didn't hear a lot
of these uh cliches these mantros
nowadays uh I want my Independence uh I
don't want to be dependent on him or
anybody and then uh they weren't saying
stuff like this were they you know Eddie
um that whole word the in that I'm an
independent woman it's it's very tricky
because what women view as as a positive
what they view as an asset we men are
looking at
as a liability now of course you can
easily just dismiss this and say oh
that's because you guys are just
intimidated of you know by strong
independent women no when you say that
I'm an independent woman in your parade
in that on all your handles and all your
videos and all your whatever it is that
you're doing right because you're doing
you when you parade that do you know
what you're sending the message you're
sending to men is hey I really don't
need you but if you want to come on
board then great but I really don't need
you and see this is where the ball drops
yeah because we as human beings and
especially men we want to feel needed we
want to feel appreciated now a woman
might come and interject and say but we
want to feel appreciated too hey I agree
with you but we men are not the ones
saying that we are independent we don't
need women we can do it on our own we're
not the ones saying it it's you women
who are saying it we're not saying that
so I believe that it's not attractive
when a man sees that and when a man sees
an independent woman it's sure do
intimidated men insecure men exist out
there yes but for a lot of men I would
argue it's not that they're intimidated
they don't want to put up with the
baggage that comes along with all that
and again this is what no one is
speaking of
can this be just for our for our dear
sisters out there sure and even uh men
who have um Fall Would you say victim
can can many of the people out there
sisters men more so on the scissor side
have just without even noticing and then
they start
mimicking certain people and they start
repeating certain phrases can they have
just you know not even knowing it and
they're watching this for his first time
and be like man I've I've fallen victim
to this I've without even knowing it and
because you think this is the norm now
this is how it should be see that's the
other thing too the truth comes with a
price and no one else is telling me
otherwise but that's the problem that's
why you keep sinking deeper and deeper
and deeper and it becomes see the more
we delay because we're strategizing and
we're trying to use wisdom the more we
delay the more it becomes difficult for
us to bring those who are already
drowning
becomes more and more difficult right
because they're sinking more and more
and more and more and I'm just saying
hey look I'm doing what I can I'm doing
what I can with whatever I can right
um and and you're going to have people
of course who are going to shun you and
there are people who are going to say I
just want to give you a quick story not
more than a minute I was recently in
Ohio and I was speaking to a group of
young men in women uh in the ages of 12
to 20. and so I got this note it wasn't
a question it was during the Q a session
after my talk and a sister wrote
for speaking the truth like it is this
is a sister now yes yeah yes the point
I'm trying to make is we have to stop
acting as though the world revolves
around those who always have a fit with
what you said it's never good enough the
ingredients are never actively
completely all there together well it's
the way you said it and I don't like
your body language and what's the Nuance
in your voice if you said it different
in other words they always have a
problem but they never check perhaps
that maybe their ego is a little bit too
big maybe they they don't have a
penetratable ego maybe they've been the
problem all along without realizing it
but that really really Lee brought me to
my knees when I saw that because I felt
as if it was a way of Allah reinforcing
me through her and it was a way of Allah
reinforcing her through me because you
you start to think that maybe this is
not the right way to go about it and I
think that's health healthy to have
these conversations but when she sent
that and she said thank you I thought to
myself subhanallah
does she not to be is she not to be
reminded
does she not need a voice to tell her
sister you're doing the right thing keep
it up why are we always focused about
well they might not come back why are we
focused on the maybe not and we
completely do away with the what's
already in the door
you're telling me they don't need a
confirmation they don't need to be
solidified they don't have hearts of
Steel they need to be reminded as well
that hey you guys are on the help with
butu you guys are doing a great job keep
doing what you're doing I think I think
they need a voice too
do you think that nowadays on the
pulpits and in the lectures that people
are are getting a not a holistic view
without a doubt the prophet saw some and
their selective Hadith and selective
parts of his life are just being shown
and people are not getting the whole
picture big time yeah absolutely you're
saying absolutely absolutely like in all
capital letters okay so you have a lot
of uh do I show you and uh Scott and
they're like who are watching right now
they're they're they want to know what
are these things we're not saying yeah
so maybe now they can also when you when
you hear when you hear when you hear
imma or hotaba and speakers talking
about the prophet salallahu what do you
usually hear oh the prophet salallahu he
was amazing to his wives if we really
went back to the Sierra we're going to
find a lot of places where the Prophet
salallahu was Stern
and he told his wives not to do certain
things right and this is normal again of
a man but what we usually hear on the
mimbud is either how the prophet saws
was an amazing husband right which again
I don't have qualms with that but when
are we going to start speaking about how
amazing his wives were is there just not
time for that is that invalid is that
not that's very important yeah very and
this is what I'm talking about that's
how they were yeah how were they with
him how were they women of taqwa how
they feared Allah how how how how much
feminine feminine they were they were
comfortable in their femininity they
were comfortable and were in the hijab
they weren't bickering about the
obligation of the hijab they weren't you
know having a problem with being mothers
with staying at home with doing right
how did that how did that woman when she
came to the prophet saws correct and I'm
just paraphrasing Hadith and she came to
talk to the prophet saw some and then he
told her he said How's your relationship
with your husband be careful because
he's your Jannah or your jahannam yeah
yeah you summer did but see did she
start arguing with him no no she didn't
say that right
she just started when he told her that
did he started debating no you didn't
have this so he said
right and this this goes with the idea
of can you have you have you seen like
uh uh yet today to have let's say and
again we qualified with a good Muslim
husband he's praying five times a day he
has fear of Allah he's you know and I
think we all know what a good husband is
he's not you know uppercut and no no no
one is suggestions he's not uh cursing
at her no calling her bad name not at
all uh let's say you know he's
fulfilling all these things maintaining
and protecting and then he goes to the
Imam they have some issue and the Imam
you know to other to say this Hadith you
think that's something you can fathom
nowadays that he'll say this Hadith to
the to the woman who came in to complain
about her husband it's it's too
difficult I mean of course you always
want to be you know you want to have
some humility to always leave that
little leg groom in there even if it's
one percent but is it like wisdom with
wisdom see here's the thing a lot of
those who are talking about to do it
with wisdom are actually not on the
field doing it uh-huh
so I I find it very I find it to be
somewhat misleading to say well do it
with wisdom well hey you're not doing it
at all if you can do it with wisdom I'll
follow your approach if your approach is
truly the working way in the model to
follow I would love to follow in your
lead but when you sit there from afar
and you're critiquing me and you're
telling me if this is not how it's done
you have to use wisdom well first off
what's the definition of wisdom so how
would you put this uh uh how would you
to put the right thing in the right
place at the right time that's wisdom so
how would you advise the uh the Muslim
marriage counselor comes in to implement
this Hadith which he's never in a
marriage counseling implemented yeah
because that's what we should we should
Implement Quran Hadith because one
brother was complaining say Amen you
know they were going to this uh very
well-known uh Muslim counselor and you
know paying for it and he's recommending
books not books from a Dean but some uh
woman out there you know who's uh
cracking jokes and uh you know in her
book that has like nothing to do with
that's not Quran and Sunnah it's like
something way out there and no one and
none of these Hadith or anything were
brought up at all towards he he wants to
be corrected he's wrong also show me
from the Quran and the Sunnah where I am
doing something wrong here I want I want
to know and then but I want you also to
tell her show her the Hadith let her
come from you also and none of that yeah
and and again this goes back to the
great great uh uh this equilibrium if
you will that exists that no we can be
tough on men but no no women are
completely off the table we can't say
anything about that when it comes to
women right and that's why I asked you
earlier right
um if I if I may open up quickly a
bracket when we're talking about
psychologists when we're talking about
Muslim counselors my advice to them is
make sure you guys have you guys are
grounded in the basics of Islam because
a lot of these theories that they're
studying they're literally taken from
liberalism secularism uh post-modernism
so it's it's a lot of these theories
right although we have the very basic
ingredients in the Quran
that we we shouldn't even have to look
for other books and self-help books and
so on and so forth yes you can find
certain benefits in them but don't
forget at the end of the day a lot of
these theories
it's not science it it's a theory it
might work and it might not work right
so so you're you're trying to be all
sophisticated and stuff and you're
studying all these things and you're
giving people the advice from what
you're saying that's coming from
liberalism from where else is this stuff
coming so for example when you have when
you have when you remember earlier when
we talked about it's a man's job right
you might for these are coming from
atheists these are coming from people
you know there might be some good there
something you can use but a lot of it is
uh yeah like for example a man in Islam
it's his job to know where his wife is
who she's befriending what she's doing
it's not that he has tabs on her all the
time but I mean it's so I think it's
only natural that any man would want to
know where his wife is yes at all times
at all times of course we're not talking
about call me when you go here comment
we're not we're not talking about the
the my new details the menu she if you
will we're talking about just overall in
general right
um so you go to this therapist or you go
to this person and no nobody should tell
you no one should have a say on where
you go on what you do that's what
they're going to say it's your own
autonomy it's your own agency right
you're free to do whatever you want
whenever you want and so that's why well
not really because I'm going to be asked
about her on Judgment Day
I can't be held responsible and for her
just to do whatever she wants however
she wants whenever she wants and I'm
just going to sit there from afar and
say oh go queen that becomes very
dangerous now of course yeah I'm putting
myself on the line I can't do that let's
make it balanced now something else
because we talked about Hellfire and
then we talked that we we mentioned the
women let's let me let me give you
another Hadith here because this is
specifically for men now who are who
enter the Hellfire because they won't be
admitted to Jenna so let's keep it fair
in Balance where this term here how
would you define it and I'm paraphrasing
the Hadith where the Prophet saws
will not enter
China is this correct yes what is it
yeah the youth is basically taken from
the word dietha and some other they say
that the youth Allah
he's okay seeing his women folk engage
in the fahisha right if you will that
the Zina or uh adultery or fornication
if you will uh with with other people
and does nothing to him but by extension
under that same umbrella is a man for
example who sees his wife dressed in a
provocative way and it does nothing to
him and he has no problem with it seeing
his wife going around with random guys
joking and giggling and they're they're
getting a little bit too intimate with
one another too friendly that's a form
of death as well extension to that yes
it all of it yes yes yes yes
um a man as well that could fall under
diatha when his when he's doing these
hijabi tutorial videos in his holding
the camera for her I mean what is going
on in your mind when he's doing what
when he's videotaping either his wife in
the camera or with her in a video and
she's all dolled up with makeup in the
eyeliner and the lip gloss and stuff
like that this could easily fall under
the other or when your wife has she's
not doing fish lips without fish lips no
I'm talking about the whole makeup the
woman is supposed to beautify her fish
lips still you know fish lips do you
mean duck lips
okay I think I got you beaten there are
you talking about the doctor yeah yeah
no that's called the duck pose I guess I
think you could maybe guys in Chicago
call it the fish live Minneapolis we
call the team um another form of the
Etha as well and that's by extension
also it it's an extension of it yes it's
a form of it it's a manifestation of
dietha when you see your woman for
example she has a profile picture and
she's she's looking dazzling right the
eyeliner the eyelashes and the the lips
and the the duck pose and you're okay
with that I fear for you in front of
Allah
and again don't be don't be mad at me
but you should know better
you you're a man and you know how men
are men it is natural for them to lust
after women so when you have your wife's
picture online
and you're okay with that how do you
sleep at night
how are you okay knowing that any random
Tom Dick or Harry is if you and your
wife in lust and after her picture
and that does absolutely nothing to you
as a man
I think we men have to step up our game
is that big time that can qualifies the
youth yes it's it's an extension of it
it's under that umbrella yes and be very
careful it's under that umbrella so if
you you've been with your wife for over
a decade sure let's say for example
she's still not wearing hijab example
it's your responsibility let's say
you've shut that advice uh clock off I
mean connect qualify you're not even
reminding anymore you know you've you've
stepped back you've just it's been over
a decade now you don't even say nothing
you've you know but you get upset if the
food's not brought to you or on these
other aspects when it suits for you I've
always found that I found that um I've
always found that puzzle in that when it
comes to certain aspects of the dean the
husband just doesn't care he's lacks but
when it comes to the food not ready or
she walked in front of the the the World
Cup and all of a sudden he'll he's ready
in front of the world yeah yeah the
World Cup uh or NBA basketball oh yeah
yeah you you walked right in front of
you loyal lawyer yeah you know all this
nonsense right up but no that's true
what you said see as a man it has to
there has you have to there has to be
this distaste in your mouth
when your wife is not obeying Allah
there has to be a distaste in your mouth
you have to show her that hey I'm I'm
not comfortable with this
right as one woman she was walking
outside
um I want to share this with you because
I think it's relevant
um a woman was walking outside
right and she wasn't dressed
appropriately so um the husband said why
are you going like that right and it was
in Arabic right
um and then he said you have to change
do ABC she said to him
you're going to make it hard you're
going to put me at unease in front of
people right if you want me to change
and not look this dazzling if he turned
around and told her Allah
by what you're doing now look in the Way
You Are
putting me at unease with Allah
right and again I think this is what we
have to kind of renormalize and get back
in our peripheral or get back in our
radar yeah wow there's a lot to uh
unpackage here tell us so before we
conclude um what are some of the other
things that you've that you've seen out
there Simple Solutions they're simple
but it's become so complex now because
the layers and layers and layers but if
we just come back to our Dean the Quran
as soon as there if we know the purpose
of life we know our roles everything is
laid out that's the beauty of Islam
everything based on evidence solid
evidence is black and white it's very
straightforward and you're gonna get
rewarded for it but also you got the
consequences you got the Hellfire is
real Paradise you know what what do you
love the most do you want to be in
Jannah right or you want to follow the
custom and culture the fashion and all
the stuff but sincerely you got a lot of
people falling victim they've Fallen
victim they've been watching too much of
the Hollywood too much of the Instagram
and Tick Tock all this stuff and it's
just uh that virus that I'm mentioned
earlier the malware comes is packaged
nice and sweet and now the poison the
virus gets into the brain and this and
the sister and the brother and they're
like how do I get out of this I love my
Creator most first and foremost I want
to submit to Allah I want to get out of
this dilemma well I actually I would um
I don't want to say the bulk of the
responsibility but
maybe I can get away with that to say I
don't think I'm being hyperbolic here to
say that the the voices mainstream dawah
in America has to change and it has to
change now before tomorrow and tomorrow
before next week right because a lot of
the voices what Muslims are hearing from
one end they're not hearing from another
and as I said earlier it gives the
perception that oh they're not on the
same page they might not disagree this
person is just extreme see that's one of
the biggest methodas that I find the
biggest evils that this whole silence
Brigade creates is that the average
Muslim looks at the person who's silent
and from that silence they understand
that oh they must not have a problem
with it but here she Rusev on the other
hand side he's so extreme and aggressive
and rigid did you hear what he said on
the mimba in ABC XYZ so we our voices
have to be on the same page right even
if no one is following it one of them I
like it I said he said that you have to
speak about the truth even if no one is
following it you're not following it
that's fine that's between you and Allah
but I want you to know deep inside the
difference between a and b that this is
wrong and this is right so I believe we
as Muslim duhat we have a responsibility
to bear
our job is to convey the message our job
is to tell the people what is Haram and
what is and we have to do it in such an
explicit way I'll give you for an
example and I think this is the right
time to talk about it what gets me
really worked up is when I see a Sheikh
an Imam a Muslim speaker right pay
attention imams and I'm not here I'm not
here to make enemies by the way right so
mom's got to pay attention this is all
with all due respect and of course of
course when when you when you sit for an
hour on end and you talk about modesty
beauty of modesty and you bring five
Hadith and you bring ten stories and
then you bring 10 ayat but you do not
tie that one hour lecture of modesty
with current events today such as the
tick tock couples the hijabi tutorialist
the woman who's sitting in front of a
camera dazzled up in makeup right for
the world to see with the light
flickering on her but you don't talk
about her and how Haram it is or when
you talk about for example this is uh
you said a big word now so you said how
Haram it is so this is Haram of course
that's yes yes
um or when you're you're ready was
anybody that studies at Medina
University as some of the great
University is this something that they
might have missed in the class like Can
someone say no [ __ ] this is like you
know fake you know this is you're too
kind daddy you're too kind you're too
charitable I wish I was on the other
side right about now
um you're too kind so this is straight
this is this is obvious so so people who
study know this this is so this is very
basic Islam okay
the woman is only to beautify herself in
front of right for her husband I wanna I
wanna maybe say this because I think
this is really really important I swear
by Allah who created us
women who do this on Judgment Day will
immediately regret it the minute they
die and I want the sister I want the
sister to listen and really to pay heed
there's not a woman who's doing this
tejab tutorial and she's putting on that
dazzling makeup on her face in front of
millions of random eyes to gaze at her
into lust after her
she's happy now with the views
she's completely euphoric feeling
euphoric with the likes with the
subscriptions with the talks with the uh
invites with with all this attention but
I swear by Allah sister the minute
you're put six feet deep
and people are still lusting after your
material
only Allah knows what's awaiting these
sisters if they don't make tawba to
Allah you're happy now but you're going
to wish when you're six feet deep that
you never got your face in front of a
camera to begin with some of our sisters
they need to hear this this is again
this is basic Islam this has been going
on for far too long and again going back
to them
when they sit here for an hour on end
talking about the Beauties and the
virtues of modesty but they don't bring
these obvious ills that are basically
happening out there and it's not that
we're picking on women the men have ills
too but the fitna of women is not like
the fitna of men
this is basic biology
all right so I find this to be a problem
when you're beating around the bush when
you're dancing around the Tulips when
you're dodging that because you know
that's going to get you in some trouble
when you say these things so send all of
your
um comments and uh if there's any I
think I think honestly I think you know
for the for the woman of taqwa uh for
the men of taqwa you know for the
Muslims of taqwa that God Consciousness
you know inshallah we all get the
strength may Allah help us but for the
fall small friends that are getting a
little riled up send it to uh send the
hate mail or the no no no no send me the
compliments the compliments send me the
compliments and give them your email for
the for the criticism Twitter handle uh
project you know this is this is uh very
important because uh we're gonna die
soon at any time and uh people have to
understand this is uh this is not like
you said earlier this is this is not out
of any hate or anything this is out of
love and this is true love when someone
is telling you something of course and
now it prevents you from just like the
doctor you know let's say you're going
to a proper doctor and the doctor's
teaching you a good Health Nutrition and
whatnot and now you got to give up some
things but you're addicted to Sugar
you're addicted to a lot of the things
that are harmful for you but the one
that wants the best for you is telling
you look if you give up these things
you're going to end up being healthier
you're going to end up being happier so
if they do these things this can be
something that can be uh Maybe not maybe
but a lot of times bringing Havoc into
your life right you're bringing the
displeasure of Allah into and for us to
stop constantly expecting the world
around us around us to change
thinking that there's nothing wrong with
us we have to start criticizing our
criticism we have to start looking at
ourselves right in the mirror and saying
perhaps there are a few I have to change
I have to start with the change not the
whole world right as though I'm always
the victim you know what I mean and I
think that's important to also you've
had you've had some of these uh some of
these uh you mentioned the hijab hijab
tutorials so one question is what would
you advise for someone who wants to
teach other women they want to they
since they want to sincerely not do it
for likes or or for you know stardom
whatever the case but they want to help
sisters who are new to Islam how would
you advise them but then also over here
uh it's good you mention is because
you've seen like um I believe it was uh
some Tokyo D Dina or something and some
others where they started off with this
and they were doing this kind of stuff
and they were drawing a lot of they got
you know a lot of attention they're
coming in then they end up leaving Islam
they they ended up started with hijab
and now women are looking at them then
mocking them and they start doing it
also but this was your example and that
example floated right out there's right
out of the dean yeah you know
or right I I you know let me let me let
me rephrase I don't know if they I'm
sorry I don't know if she left Islam but
she left hijab and slowly I don't well I
don't know who you're speaking of by the
way I I I'm not sure this was a little
some time ago but you have many of these
uh but it's not it's it's it's happening
more and more frequently you're seeing
that now yeah either taking off the
hijab or just leaving Islam or whatever
the case is but this is this is the
hotel shaitaan you think you're just
gonna do a you know you're just gonna do
a these are the footsteps of without a
doubt yes without a doubt so what would
you advise the sister then now maybe she
has her account she's guys it's a
challenge now she's got uh a hundred uh
pictures posing out there on Instagram
and whatnot dear sister wallahi take it
from me I get nothing out of this
there's not a man who looks at your
picture and is enticed by your picture
only that you bear a form of
responsibility and a portion of that
responsibility and that sin on Judgment
Day we have to look at it in terms of
numbers so a sister when she looks at
the likes I mean let's assume I don't
know let's throw a figure out there 500
how many people are lusting after the
sister right 400 per day 500 per day a
thousand per day right now take these
numbers and translate them into sins
a thousand sins a day
how many maybe it's far beyond that
right
um so this is something that we have to
really really keep in mind that
this is not going to go scot-free it's
all happy now with likes shares comments
you're getting all these invites you're
getting all of the attention right but
before you get all uppity and too
excited honestly remember dear sister
that when you're six feet deep
and you die and you're alone in a grave
it's dark there's nothing there right
and then you find out that people are
still watching your content men are
still lusting after your pictures men
are still looking at your content
so instead of you getting good deeds
after your death you're racking up a lot
of evil only to come on Judgment Day
with so much evil that only Allah knows
I don't think any sane person is ready
ready for this but this is this is the
language that we have to start speaking
the language of numbers right and I
think that this is the best way of
moving forward yeah as we said earlier
this is something that's basic 101 Dean
there's no
difference of opinion I mean this is 101
just like you're going to English
classroom class this is basal base 101
on how we conduct ourselves as
practicing Muslims male or female right
and same thing for the brothers out
there is there example like I mean you
mentioned it's more for the Sisters but
you know for let's say the reason here
and again this this because no brother
should be out there showing his Aura you
know taking his shirt showing his thighs
and all this other stuff here's here's
the difference though and not that I'm
not that we're looking to fault the
sisters but when the sisters do it they
do it under the umbrella of religion oh
I see what you're saying do you see the
difference yes a brother who's doing out
there I don't think he's looking for
religious legitimization but the sister
when she has on the symbol of Islam the
hijab there is Islam in there some way
and it's a form of legitimization that
hey I'm going to wear the hijab and you
can look dazzling while you're at it and
you can have this spunk in your walk and
you can do this and do that and all the
makeup but that's the reason I think
this is the difference that people are
not really catching on to the brother
who's doing the lifting of the weights
or whatever it is of course we don't
recommend that he does that right I
think we we have to all be modest I
don't recommend it but I'm going to be
very honest here the severity of that
sister is not like the severity of that
brother
the fitna of women is not like the fitna
of men
I know that's not going to resonate with
a lot of people especially the world
culture but this is an obvious fact the
fit of women is not like the fitna of of
uh of men right no and then uh just
having having more um of an attitude in
this with uh the community leaders you
really want them to take more of an
initiative to talk about many of these
specifics of course I think we have to
be more vocal we have to be direct we
have to be straightforward we have to be
blunt we have to we have to basically
call a spade a spade not to do it rudely
or to be inconsiderate right but at the
same time it has to be done we cannot
cling on to this idea of with wisdom and
we're we're having a good talk uh for 20
years about wisdom and we still haven't
yet delivered the about you know women
doing this online or Brothers doing this
online we we have to come to a
realization that the young Muslims
generation they are thirsty
they are thirsty for this and they have
to hear it and there's good I believe
there is honestly good Muslim as out
there in good Muslims out there all they
need is for someone to guide them
all they need is for someone to tell
them you're playing with fire I'm just
letting you know you're playing some
people need to be roughed up like that
this whole pattern on the back and
Allah's most gracious most merciful
we've become somewhat like Christianity
and this is why a lot of Muslims are
starting to view Islam no different than
the way Christians will view
Christianity because we're talking so
much about the mercy of Allah some
people become more complacent and some
people enjoy and validate their sin and
more every time they hear about the
mercy of Allah there's no sense of
urgency you can only talk about that so
much until now you have to start
flipping the script
right and I think again the time is now
now before tonight and tonight before
tomorrow yeah yeah inshallah this can be
a benefit this can uh also motivate some
of the uh Dua Scholars out there who are
Community leaders imams to touch upon
this so they see you talking about it
you're brave enough and uh oh no I well
I don't see it Brave I I don't know if
I'm being Reckless honestly right about
now but um yeah I I just it's when you
study Islam you know that there's
you're responsible to convey this
message
Allah has taken an oath from the people
of the book you would make it clear to
the people and you would not conceal it
yeah people are people the average
Muslim is already confused your silence
is adding confusion to the already
confused Muslim are you honestly telling
me that's not a disaster a recipe for
disaster yeah this is not the time to
remain silent
yeah and then uh when we when we put
things in perspective if you're somebody
who knows what your purpose in life is
and that purpose is to please your
creator before you meet your creator so
you're trying your best your humble best
to submit your will to the will of Allah
to the creator of heavens and earth and
Islam and that's by the guidance of the
Quran the verbatim word of God Almighty
understand
he's supposed to be upon them so when
the truth comes to you and the saying oh
the truth will set you free if you want
more peace and happiness in your life
contentment you're not going to get it
it's not going to taste good it's not
going to taste good uh-huh
but it's going to be good for you in the
long run yeah some of these things and
that might like the shot coming in at
first doesn't feel good working out a
lot of times it's torture you know what
I mean the results are there so the
results if you want to please Allah you
want to get to Jannah you're going to
have to tame that Nest you're going to
have to tame and the next thank you for
bringing that up because look I know
shaitaan is probably wanting you to look
me up to cancel me to call all your MSA
members never have this guy on our
campus again but look well like if you
were to just pump your brakes a bit
you'll realize that your ego is your
enemy not me and that's a real dangerous
thing if you think for all of us we need
to take heed because the prophet saws
again mentioning this uh another Hadith
said the one who has an Adam's weight of
Kibler Pride yeah and will not enter
Jannah and then the sahaba what they say
they say look we like to dress nice you
know what not and he said no no it's
when the truth comes to you and you
reject it yep is that what it is
free to despise people and reject the
truth so we got to be people love when
the truth comes just because you don't
like how it was packed is the truth is
the truth you got to do your best to
submit to it now and and you know even
though we're delving into something
completely different though is maybe
that's your trial maybe your test is
how are you going to react
to a lot of this quote-unquote
controversial material are you going to
dismiss it or are you saying I really
got a lot of work to do are you going to
throw a fit now and you know who is this
guy think he is and I can't believe he
said this and
your test
Allah is testing you to see how you're
going to deal with this yeah in our
tests vary we're all we're being tested
differently may Allah help us and truth
comes to us to submit to the truth and
make it easy to follow it all the way to
the end to generally I mean and this
again I just reiterate this is out of
the love you know the love we're doing
this we want the best
for Humanity for our brothers and
sisters out there so we're bringing on
these important topics and having people
like you discuss
thank you very much it was a pleasure
being on here thank you very much
pleasure having you and thank you guys
once again for tuning in and subscribing
if you haven't already and if you're
somebody who is new to the channel and
you're just liking what we're talking
about you want to learn more about Islam
visit the deanshow.com pick up your free
copy of the Quran and whenever you're
confused fall down and make sincere Dua
and everything is there in our Dean how
we should act in all situations
this is all there for us in the Quran
the Sunnah it's very straightforward and
then you have the best of generations
The Companions and those who follow them
you have everything you know there in
the books hit the books take a time off
from The Tick Tock and the Instagram and
getting all this information clouding
your mind you're getting confused go
back to the people of knowledge it's
really straightforward and clear and
we'll see you next time here on the dean
show until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum